do you think uh if Israel could they
would avoid the death of any
civilians so you're saying there's some
degree of punishment of collective
they're purposely killing civilians it's
this is the Iron Wall they're trying to
beat the Palestinians in a
submission
right there's no way you kill this many
civilians
um if you're trying to precisely take
out Hamas Fighters and by the way the
Israeli spokesman the IDF spokesman has
explicitly said that we are not pursuing
Precision bombing and that what we are
doing is trying to you know maximize the
amount of Destruction and damage uh that
we can inflict on the
Palestinians and uh I I I think this is
a major mistake on the part of Israel
first of all it ends up being a moral
stank on your reputation number one and
number two it doesn't work it doesn't
work the the Palestinians are not going
to roll over and submit to uh Israeli
domination of their
life um so you know the whole concept of
the Iron Wall uh gabatin Sky's term was
misguided um and and and by the way the
iron if you look at what the Israelis
are doing they're trying to do two
things one is the Iron Wall and that's
where you punish the civilian population
in Gaza and get them to submit the other
thing that they're trying to do is get
Hamas they want to destroy Hamas and the
belief there is that if they destroy
Hamas they've solved the problem but as
many Israelis know including people on
the hard right even if you destroy Hamas
they are going to be replaced by another
group another resistance group uh and
that resistance group will employ Terror
yeah I think you I think you've said
that uh other terrorist organizations
have used the situation in Palestine as
a as a kind of a recruit recruitment
mechanism for for a long time Osama bin
lad made it clear that this was one of
those principal reasons for attacking
the United States right and the United
States attacked back and uh got us into
a 20-year war that cost
the lives of millions of people not not
American but uh human
beings and uh engaged in torture in
torture yeah no I think if you look at
how we reacted to
911 and how the Israelis are reacting to
what happened on October 7th uh there's
uh quite a bit of similarity in that
both sides the Israeli side and the
American side uh are enraged right and
they lash out and they go on a
rampage and the end result is not good
is there capacity within Israel or with
within United States after 911 to do
something approximating turn the other
cheek
of understanding the root of Terror is
hate and fighting that hate with
uh not the sound naive but
compassion well I I don't think in
either case you're going to turn the
other cheek uh I think well some I what
I mean by that is some limited powerful
military response but very limited yeah
coupled with a smart political strategy
political strategy diplomacy yeah that's
what they should have done yeah right
but is there capacity for that or from
your
offensive realism perspective it's just
the odds are really
low no for my offensive realist
perspective or my realist perspective
that's what you should do right okay my
my view is states are rational actors
they should be cunning right they should
think about uh the Strategic situation
they're in and choose the appropriate
response and uh what happens and this is
why my theory is not always correct is
that sometimes state are not rational
and they
misbehave I would argue in the Israeli
case uh that it would have been good
after October 7th or starting on October
7th if the United States had uh tried to
hold the Israelis back and
countenanced uh a more uh moderate
response more with uh to to SP take some
time just to think about how to deal
with this problem instead of lashing out
I I think given what happened to the
Israelis given how shocked they were
given the level of fear given the level
of Rage they were going to lash out and
I don't believe that was in their
interest I think it would have been made
would have made sense to to think about
it and uh to think about a smarter
strategy than they're now employing and
I think you know the Americans blew it
the Americans gave him a bare hug and a
green light and said we'll give you all
the Weaponry you need and go out and do
it and uh I don't think that was the
smart thing to do look in the wake of
October 7th the Israelis had no good
strategy right it's it's not like
there's a magic formula that they just
didn't see and we should have told them
what the magic formula was right that's
not true they were in a sense caught
between a rock and a hard place in terms
of what to do but they're smarter things
and Dumber things and I think the
Israelis lashed out in ways that are
counterproductive I think you know going
on a rampage and you know killing huge
numbers of civilians is not it's
obviously morally wrong but it's also
just not in their strategic interest
right I mean uh cuz it's it's not going
to buy them anything right and in fact
it's going to cost them right because
people all over the planet are turning
against Israel uh I saw you know an
Israeli think tank today uh that has
been tracking uh protests around the
world um gave some figures for what it
looked like uh between October 7th and
October 13th in terms of the number of
uh protests around the world that were
pro-israel versus Pro Palestine and then
it looked at the numbers from U October
13th up to the present and I think the
numbers were 69% were Pro Palestinian in
the first six days after October 7th
69% and I think 31% take these numbers
with a grain of salt 31% were pro-israel
so I think it was 69 and
31 um and uh since then since October
13th if you look at the number of
protests around the world 95% have been
Pro Palestinian and 5% have been
pro-israel uh and what this tells you is
that public opinion around the world has
shifted against Israel and if you look
at some of the demonstrations in places
like London and Washington DC it's truly
amazing the number of people who are
coming out in support of the
Palestinians
and uh all of this again is just to
support my point that it was just not
smart for Israel to uh launch this
bombing campaign right you can make an
argument for going after Hamas and doing
it in a surgical way or as surgical a
way as possible uh but uh that's not
what they did and again my point to you
is I think that this punishment campaign
is not going to work strategically in
other words not going to beat the
Palestinians into submission they're not
going to finish off Hamas and at the
same time by pursuing this strategy
they're doing huge damage to their
reputation around the world well I just
uh yeah in the wake of October
7th given the geopolitical
context I think there's a lot of
Leverage to be the great ethical
superpower that demonstrate power
without killing any
civilians and use that leverage
diplomatic leverage to push forward
something like abrahamic Accords with
more nations with with Saudi Arabia push
for peace aggressively peace agreements
this kind of stuff economic
relationships all this kind of stuff and
thereby pressure the Palestinian
Authority you know towards
um perhaps a two-state
solution but I think what you're missing
here just in the Israeli case is that
the Israeli government is not interested
in the two-state solution and you want
to remember that Benjamin Netanyahu who
looks very hawkish when you look at him
in
isolation doesn't look so hawkish when
you look at him compared to the rest of
the people in his
cabinet right he he he almost looks like
a moderate he's got a lot of people who
are way out to the right of him
and these people and this of course
includes Netanyahu are not interested in
the two-state solution so the question
you have to ask yourself is you if
you're if you're Benjamin Netanyahu and
it's July 7th late in the excuse me
October 7th late in the day what do you
do you're not thinking about a two-state
solution you're thinking about an
occupation that's not going to end and
the question is how do you deal with the
Palestinians given what's just
happened well there's people in the
cabinet and then there's history and
history remembers great leaders and
so uh Benjamin and yahu can look in the
streets of Israel and see the protests
and think of how history will remember
him and I think a two-state solution is
on the table for a great leader well it
was there was he the person who was
gonna take advantage of it I don't think
so but well he's a student of History
well at this point what the will see
does I mean it's very at this point it's
very difficult um like you said 95% now
or whatever the number is of protests I
think the the window in which Israel has
the ears of the world they can do the
the big ethical peace act action towards
peace is uh I think as closed or maybe
there's still a slowther but it's just
uh
uh the slippery slope of of hate is has
taken off it's quite depressing to watch
what's going I agree 100% unequivocally
depressing